[Music]
hi I'm Jolene and this is like a
property investor
[Music]
so here we are back in Sunderland ten
days after we got the keys so we should
have been 17 days but the vendor
solicitor thing that people work signed
them back to us on time so things got
delayed by one week so we've had to get
the tenant she's staying with her sister
so we've had to extend that by a week
and we put the refurb team back by week
which was a bit frustrating but we've
got the record done once the paperwork
was signed the electricians been in and
on his first fix so we'll the electrics
have done in the kitchen and bits and
pieces have being done around the rest
of the property and the plasters are now
in making everything look tidy ready for
the bathroom and kitchen to be fitted on
phase 2 so I'll take you inside come
this way
brilliant so here we are in the dining
room so you can see it's all being
stripped out there's no flooring on the
floor or radiator and stuffs still here
the windows and things are all still in
place so in in this room here you can
literally just see the flooring has been
removed but as you move further round
property you'll see all the other work
that's been going on so if we now move
into the kitchen which you probably
remember is a bit of a statement I'm so
sting rips out and yes big totally
ripped out the electrician's been in
done his first fix so we've got all the
new plug sockets all been chiseled into
the walls and Clint the plasters are
here and they're plastering up now ready
for the fit of the kitchen probably in a
week's time so once the plasters nice
and dry so at the moment it's in the
heat wave of the UK's I think today or
tomorrow supposed to be the hottest day
that we've ever had and certainly up
north it's a normally a bit chilly but
the plasters should dry a fair bit
quicker which is good news the other
issue that we had was there's quite a
few months so we've got well we respect
to rental Geller and the council
and then we came around and we baited
all the mice so hopefully that will no
longer be a problem and definitely
shouldn't be a problem later on which is
great news so move on to the lounge just
what's the Oldham what we found as we've
all gone round property some of the
floorboards have been rotten so we had
to take those floorboards out so there's
the old hole hole in the floor we're in
the lounge fireplace being removed
there's that horrible separating wood
aisle halfway mall so that's all been
bought off the electrics have been
reworked so they've got me a lot tidier
of an in the alcoves you can pull them
there's a light and it is so high up you
can get the light bulb out of the light
so I'm not quite sure how they fitted
them but with operty made arrangements
are they going to be wired in a bit
lower which is cool radiators off the
wall and that's about to be ditched and
you can probably tell that the property
doesn't probably looks a bit worse than
in what I've done to begin with but you
got to make it look a lot worse to then
make it look good at the end so that's
good was just going upstairs I mean just
thief on this wall here we haven't
replaster the whole wall of expenses and
it didn't need it
so we've just read Glosser the middle of
it which was quite broken and all the
bits above and below are good so we're
just going to redecorate those as and
when there were literally I'm just
walking around the house from the
plasters and the applause for atomic
down the stairs and he's pretty much
gone through the floor and they're
floorboards at the bottom of the stairs
are rotten so it's very lucky we found
that out at this stage so we can put
that right but you can just see yeah I
mean I might being woodworm or something
in them so we'll get that put right
brilliant right upstairs so let's have a
look at the bathroom
the bathrooms been ripped out you'll be
able to see there's some nice retro
colors from the past so I guess my mouse
was first built most turquoise violet
purple yellow blue
and now I have plastic sheeting and then
we're gonna tile over it we should be
good we moved into the bathroom
obviously did the rip out rotten boards
at the end of the bath down on the floor
so we'll need to replace those and get
those put right and otherwise ripped out
the back the fan says a good draft
coming in it's very the UM where the
farm was before otherwise we're waiting
for it all to be plastered ready for the
new bathroom to be fitted so that will
happen okay so we're in bedroom number
one there's a load of condensation up on
the back wall there so we had a quad
could look at the windows and rather
than replacing the windows what we're
gonna do and we're going to replace it
or we're gonna look at all the gaskets
and replace all of those we're getting
change all the handles and then we're
going to put vents in the top and the
bottom so there's a bit of airflow to
stop the condensation the dump from
happily so we're in bedroom number two
not a huge lots going on but we have we
plastered all the ceilings so they're
now all nice and flat before that you
can probably remember the old texture
that was quite popular in the 60s and
70s and that has now gone ready for the
decorators to move in next what's this
alright we're in bedroom number three
which you will have the double beds in
it double bunk beds for the two young
boys it was a bit of a nightmare to get
into before so I think what will need to
happen so when he's changed the door
pins out onto the other side but then
we'll also need to move the lights which
are the over the door so when you open
it it's just sat there ready for you to
go we also had a horrible box before
which you have to climb over which came
out from here
she went square down which you also have
to clamber over so we're taking that box
out and then we're going to just reapply
on a diagonal going down where the
stairs are which won't put a lot more
room in
into the room and lastly we've got a
little window up here which is Tony
Fallone so that will need replacing it
doesn't even close at the moment so in
the winter the two little boys have to
go and sleep of the month and you can
see all the condensation and stuff in
them it in the middle so there's no
retrieving that so that'd be our nice
new button by the figures for this house
so it's we bought it for sixty four
thousand and essentially we've done a
exchange non standard delayed completion
so what that means is that your exchange
you put down your 10% deposit and then
you get the keys and the non stand up it
means that you are then allowed to move
into the property you're unable to
refurb it and then on completion you can
get bridging finance and then you can
refinance it on then on the new done-up
value so essentially you're only having
to put down 10% plus the refurb cost
rather than having to pay 25% plus plus
refurb cost so that's one way of
overcoming well not having to put so
much so much money down to pick them
with in your in your deal the other way
of doing a property like this is do to
do an assisted sale so within an
assisted so you essentially set up a
assignable short-term lease option
agreement so you walk into the property
you agree with the vendor that you're
paying the sixty four thousand pounds
you then do all your work once you pay
the vendor an option fee you do all the
work and you have to really assure them
that you're investing X amount in during
the refurb so you might be spending
fifteen twenty thousand pounds and doing
it so therefore you've got you're not
going to let just let the option expire
then on completion you assign it to the
third party so the new buyer so this is
land that's where the assistance comes
in because the new person would not be
able to it it what probably couldn't get
the
the vendor on site speaking with or
might not have connection with the
vendor and then they wouldn't be able to
afford until the reef urban things which
obviously it takes cash in your back
pocket so that's the idea behind the
assistance assisted so so we'll be
looking at one of those two options to
structure the deal really so that's the
house
so we've seen a delay so we're now ten
days in the refurb we've come in we
stripped it all out done the electrics
stopped mostly got down the plastering a
bit more to go
plastering in the kitchen once that's
done we'll get the kitchen fitted well
then get the bathroom fitters well then
get it all decorated and get the
flooring done and then ready for the
talent to move back in in the beginning
of August so tight timelines but I think
we're well we're we're on track
[Music]
you